Das war's für heute.
Ach so, ja, das ist das Übliche.
Das, was es immer anzeigt.
Was?
Ah, Sepparo, der Nico spielt Overwatch.
Wo hast du denn das gesehen? Streamt er auch?
So, auf geht's.
Oh, ich bin auch voll im Arsch irgendwie, ne?
Ich meine, ihr kennt das vielleicht, wenn man gerade frisch aufgestanden ist.
Dann ist man auch so irgendwie kaputt.
So, ich weiß auch nicht.
Eigentlich müsste ich jetzt erstmal eine Runde rumrennen, dass ich wieder wach werde irgendwie.
Keine Ahnung.
Lull.
Das sackt aber echt.
Wo ist mein Mauszeiger?
Was, die haben echt Overwatch zusammengespielt, Sepparo?
Nicht schlecht. Und, wie haben sie sich so geschlagen?
Habt ihr eigentlich schon Cheater gesichtet?
So, mal eine Frage.
Ich hab' heute auf Twitter gelesen, die ersten Leute.
Ich muss, ich muss mal kurz nebenbei Kopfhörer entwirken.
Ich hoffe mal, dass ich was sehe.
What the fuck, was ist mit meinem Kopfhörer?
So, ist besser.
Ich hab' heute auf Twitter gelesen, die ersten Leute haben das Game schon zurückgegeben.
Ich werd' das Game nicht zurückgeben.
Ich geb' das Game höchstens zurück.
Was?
Hä? Woher weißt du denn, dass der Niko Overwatch spielt?
Ich werd' das Game höchstens zurückgeben, wenn es Cheater gibt.
Also jetzt innerhalb der ersten paar Tage.
Ich bin immer noch so richtig kaputt irgendwie.
Erstmal aufwachen.
Jetzt bräuchte ich schon meinen Boxsack hier, der steht aber drüben.
Da könnt ich ein bisschen drauf rumhauen.
Dann wär ich wach.
So, auf geht's.
Jetzt müssen wir uns erstmal diesen tollen Social Hub angucken.
Hier ist ganz schön was los.
Und ich hab' irgendwo Rewards, glaube ich, die ich einsammeln kann.
Wir payen Respekt.
Ich hab' fast das Gefühl gehabt, die wollten sich selbst verarschen mit, dass man F drücken muss bei dem Typ.
Auf der anderen Seite glaube ich das auch wiederum nicht.
Moment, wo konnte man den Scheiß noch mal abgeben?
Äh, bei, ups.
Boah, hier ist richtig was los. Jetzt könnt ihr euch dran erinnern, bei Release, da war hier nichts.
Hier sieht man natürlich auch schön, was die anderen für Supply Drops gekriegt haben.
Wir werfen jetzt auch mal unsere Supply Drops hier hin.
Einfach weil es geht. Gucken wir mal, was wir da rauskriegen.
Was hab' ich da jetzt von? Kann man sich das irgendwie angucken?
Man kann draufklicken, aber das passiert nichts, wenn man draufklickt. Das ist auch toll.
Supply Dropen wir mal weiter.
Ich muss hier mal weg, da sind mir zu viele Leute am Start.
Wisst ich, Alde.
Next Supply Drop. Ach, den darf man hier nicht hinlegen.
Ah, die Supply Drops, die muss man hier vorne hinlegen, dass es auch schön viele Leute sehen.
Ähm, jetzt, wie ist der Zombie-Modus?
Epic!
Jawoll, jetzt geht's ab hier. Schlag auf Schlag.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wo man das Zeug ausrüstet. Das müssen wir gleich noch mal anschauen.
Ach so, das ist einfach nur zum Anschauen. Okay.
Der Fly-Boy. Next.
Noch mal einen Crip. Ich hab' so viele Crips, so viele Waffen hab' ich geändert.
Und wie viele Supply Drops hab' ich eigentlich?
Lohnt sich der Zombie-Modus erst? Also bringt das was, wenn man das mal sich anguckt?
Also ich war ja kein großer Fan von Zombies in den letzten, was heißt kein großer Fan?
Ich hab's wenig gespielt, Zombies. Viele Leute sagen, der Zombies war der einzig brauchbare Modus der letzten paar Call of Duty-Teile.
Noch mehr Epic.
Tashcan.
Wie viele hab' ich davon eigentlich? Ich hab's halt da ganz schön auf.
Das rüstet mir gleich aus.
Ah, jetzt hab' ich nix mehr.
Contracts. Hab' ich irgendwas abgeschlossen?
Moment.
Contract ist was anderes als diese Missions, die ich mir da eben abgeholt hab'.
Contract ist anscheinend irgendwie so eine kurzfristige Aufgabe.
Drei Headshots in Any Mode, das schaffen wir.
Konsolmenü, lul.
100 Kills. Ja, das dauert in der Test-Match ne Weile.
Ja, erst mal angucken. So, jetzt müssen wir zum...
A Collection Item from the Quartermaster müssen wir noch machen.
Moment, bei der waren wir doch gerade.
So viel Zeug, ey. Und so viel unsinniges Zeug. Wozu braucht man das überhaupt?
Yeah, man.
Ich hab' überhaupt keinen Bock mich damit zu beschäftigen.
Das ist doch eh alles nur Kosmetik, ne?
Raufgeschissen. Gehen wir jetzt raus und suchen ein Match.
Aber vorher schauen wir uns noch mal an, was wir hier ausrüsten können.
Haben wir neue.
Reload faster and while sprinting.
Das finde ich gut.
Und haben wir bei dem Ding noch was zum draufsetzen. Extra Damage against streaks.
Nein, das ist Mist, das brauchen wir nicht.
Steady aim. Steady aim ist wichtig. Reflex side, land side eigentlich.
Eigentlich brauchen wir überhaupt keine Zeit dabei.
Aber lieber schnell das aiming down side.
So, auf geht's.
Achso, ja, kill streaks. Kill streaks muss ich noch customisern.
Ja, stimmt. Contracts kosten in-game Werbung.
Fighter-Pilot. Was macht der Fighter-Pilot? Das muss ich jetzt mal gucken.
Fighter-Pilot.
Zum Glück steht halt nicht da, was es macht, ne?
Fighter-Pilot, kurz mal gucken, was das Ding macht. Das ist so ein Chopper-Gunner oder sowas.
Ja, das ist so eine Art Chopper-Gunner.
Aber man kann nur einmal wohl fliegen.
Irgendwo kann man streaks testen. Ich finde das ganze Menü übelst unübersichtlich.
Also das ganze, wie das aufgebaut ist, vielleicht dauert es auch nur ein bisschen bis man reinkommt.
Ich will es nicht abenden.
Hier sieht man also auch, wenn man...
Ok, so, Match suchen.
Schon im Prestige? Nein, nein, ich bin noch nicht im Prestige. Ich bin Level 17, hallo.
Map-Vote.
Ok, kann ich voten? Oder geht es wieder nicht mit Maus, weil...
Weil Konsolen-Menü...
Nein, mit Q, mit...
Das geht natürlich nicht, dass man da unten draufklickt, obwohl es so aussieht.
Läuft das Spiel jetzt besser als in der Beta? Ja.
Das Spiel läuft viel besser als in der Beta.
Nachdem ich jetzt aber alles ausgeschaltet habe, am Anfang lief es richtig beschissen bei Release.
Mit den Default-Grafik-Settings, also richtig schlecht zu 37 FPS.
Und jetzt, nachdem ich alles auf Low gestellt habe, wohlgemerkt mit der 1080 Ti alles auf Low gestellt.
So ist das, Cod Port. Jetzt läuft es gut.
Und natürlich auch heute.
Auf geht's. Mal jetzt erstmal ein bisschen aufwärmen.
Map spiele ich zum ersten Mal.
Oh, ein bisschen laut.
Ein bisschen laut, alles hier.
Ich mach jetzt mal einen Ticken leiser.
So, ups.
Go, go.
Ist immer schlecht, wenn man die Maps zum ersten Mal spielt.
Ich hab Input-Lag.
Übels Input-Lag. Warum? Was ist hier los?
Jetzt geht's.
Call of Duty Tod von der Seite, so muss das sein.
Ja, die 1080 Ti ist einfach mega schlecht. Stimmt schon.
Offensichtlich. Die ist so schlecht.
Oh, warte, Bällchen.
Da geh ich schnell durch.
Das sieht gleich nach Instant Death aus, wenn ich da durchgehe.
Ich muss weg.
Ich schieße mit Warte, Bällchen. Die Gegner wallhitten mich. So muss das sein.
Welche Waffe ist gerade OP? Was muss man nehmen, um alles wegzuauen?
Kennt sich damit schon jemand aus?
Flanken wir mal außen rum.
Wo geht's lang? Wo geht's lang?
Hier geht's lang.
Der flankt jetzt hier unten lang oder so. 100 pro. Was? Perpiss dich, alter.
Hinter mir. Wo ist der nächste?
Linke Seite, kommt einer.
Oh Mann, Schneiberkacke.
WTF, der guckt genau auf meinen Kopf. Alter, was soll das?
Rekt. Unkorrekt.
Mein Chat ist kaputt, ich sehe nichts mehr.
Was machen wir hier noch mal? Gibt es eigentlich auch...
Von wo? Gibt es eigentlich auch Nahkampfwaffen, die mit One-Hit-Killen?
Ich habe so ein angeblich unkaputtbares Mousepad von Rocket.
Es ist kaputt.
Ich kann das Game echt noch nicht einschätzen, wo was kommt, wann was kommt.
Vor allem, wie viel auf einmal kommt. WTF?
Wenn man das Bayonett hat, okay.
Oh, habe ich zu laut? Ja, das kann sein.
Da ich den Sound ein bisschen zu laut habe.
Sag mal, ist der blind?
Jetzt wird geschneibt. Achtung Leute.
Krasses Schneiber-Action.
Rekt. Und jetzt switchen und den Typ hinter mir baschen. Der kommt jetzt hier bestimmt rein.
Jawoll, so muss das sein.
Kurz warten, bis wir gerekt sind.
Na, super.
Was in-Game ist eher zu leise. In-Game kann schon ein bisschen lauter machen.
Das klappt.
Moment, irgendwie habe ich nur 80 FPS.
Warum habe ich so wenig FPS und das letzte Mal 140?
Es ruckelt, es ruckelt. WTF?
Hat das Ding wieder meine Settings umgestellt?
Oder was ist hier los?
Das letzte Mal hatte ich 140 FPS.
Also mit Game läuft gut war vielleicht auch ein bisschen zu schnell die Aussage.
Aber wahrscheinlich ist die 1080 DI viel zu schlecht.
Jetzt sind es 69 FPS.
Das Ding hat bestimmt meine Grafik-Settings resettet.
Ich gehe jetzt mal in die Settings rein und dann ist wahrscheinlich...
Ich darf aber nirgendwo rein.
So, die Maus leckt auch im Menü übelst.
Ich schubs die Maus jetzt nur ganz kurz an und es dauert eine halbe Sekunde gefühlt bis sie sich bewegt.
Sehr, sehr merkwürdig.
Ok, das VF hat sich resettet. Kein Wunder, dass das Game so komisch ausgesehen hat.
Wobei das war Absicht, dass ich das limitiert habe um 145.
Und irgendwie der Input abhängig ist von der FPS-Zahl.
Ganz merkwürdig.
Bei mir sieht alles noch so aus.
Komm, wir stellen das wieder hoch.
Auf geht's.
Und wir Fullscreen.
Ob das wirklich an Window...
Eigentlich darf sowas nicht an Window-Mode liegen.
Ich habe es absichtlich auf Window-Mode, weil in Fullscreen ist es in der Beta noch mehr abgekackt.
Ich habe eine 1080 DI.
Guckt ihr, seht ihr wie die Maus ruckelt? WTF?
Das ruckelt?
Was geht denn hier bitte schön gerade ab?
Ich glaube ich muss es nochmal neu... Das ruckelt? 40 FPS? What the...
Alter, 32?
Wir haben gestern die gleiche oder vorgestern die gleiche Map gespielt.
Da hatte ich 125 FPS. Moment.
Das geht so nicht.
Das müssen wir nochmal beenden jetzt.
Wir machen das jetzt nochmal aus und nochmal an.
Und dann gucken wir nochmal.
Weil ich meine, das kann es ja nicht sein.
Machst du OBS-Screen-Capture? Ich mache das mit OBS.
Wir müssen auch nicht den Fehler bei meinem Setup suchen, weil das Setup funktioniert.
Das funktioniert seit ein paar Monaten schon und das hat auch schon in diesem Game ohne Probleme funktioniert.
Neben Cheatern ist das die zweite Variante, warum ich das Game zurückgeben würde.
Wenn es halt einfach nicht richtig läuft.
Das ist ganz schön kaputt.
Fetching Online Profil.
25 FPS. Wird ja immer besser.
Fight Match, Public Match, Blah, Teamless Match. Sollen wir mal gucken, wie es jetzt ist?
Ist das FOF denn immer noch das richtige FOF?
Nein. Warum resetet sich das FOF? Was soll das?
Das ist ganz schön kaputt.
Ich glaube, es ist zu spitzen und zurückgeben. Ja, kann sein.
Aber es hält sich in Grenzen.
Ich meine, es ist jetzt nicht so, als müsste ich dann morgen irgendwie im Bahnhof irgendwo Essen holen,
weil ich jetzt Call of Duty gekauft habe und kein Geld mehr hätte oder so.
Oh, 24 FPS. So macht das Spaß.
Erx, wie läuft es bei dir eigentlich auf dem Rechner? Läuft es gut?
Du hast jetzt ja einen ziemlich ähnlichen Rechner wie ich mit meinem neuen.
Okay, jetzt haben wir 170 FPS gehabt gerade. Mal gucken, wie das sobald die Runde losgeht.
122.
Guckt mal, Leute, es ist die gleiche Map. Seht ihr den Unterschied?
Und wir haben nichts anderes gemacht.
Diese Sniper-Kacke geht mir ja jetzt schon so was von Gras auf den Sack. Das gibt es nicht.
Ja, und außerdem, da hat der Chat recht. Das menschliche Auge sieht eh nur mit 12 FPS mal 2.
Ey! Oh, diese Sniper.
Das war in der Beta noch nicht so nervig.
Was geht?
Kann ich aus dem Spawn raus? Ich kann ja gar nichts machen.
Ich habe wieder Input-Lag.
Ich glaube, da kommt was von hinten.
Wo ist der Sniper?
Wo ist der Typ? Wo geht es denn hier rauf? Wo geht es rauf?
Der wollte mich Panic Knifen.
Moment, warum habe ich noch keinen Recon Plane?
Den holen wir uns. Den holen wir uns. Oh, der ist schon tot.
Und wo kommt hier was? Recon?
Fuck, Munition leer. Der wirft eine Granate.
Jetzt wird geregt. Okay, oder wir werden geregt.
Panic Knife gibt es nicht mehr, nee. Panic Knife gibt es nicht mehr. Es gibt jetzt nur noch diesen, ich zeige es euch, das hier.
Da, Kick. Schlag. Bombe, Bombe, Bombe, Bombe.
Die Jäger drücken uns übelst ins Spawn.
Ich muss weg.
Was soll ich denn da machen? Hallo? Fünf Gegner um einen drum herum.
Ich glaube, der Nahkampf macht ungefähr 50 Leben. Ich habe es noch nicht ausprobiert.
Ich camp mal kurz, ich habe keine Ahnung, wo die kommen.
Sprengen, Sprengen. Die Gegner kommen von da jetzt, oder?
Ich bin nur voller Stürmsor. Dabei ist es viel zu übertrieben hier lang zu stürmen.
Und die Time To Kill wirkt auch ziemlich kurz. Ich hatte das Gefühl, das war in der Beta noch nicht ganz so wild.
Moment, die kommen gerade von beiden Seiten.
Das sind wieder so Tode. Ich bin gefühlt sofort tot, obwohl ich gerade richtig auf den schießen konnte.
Time To Kill zu kurz? Ich weiß es nicht. Also mit SMGs kommt es mir so vor, als schießt du teilweise Wartebällchen.
Aber ich werde jetzt erstmal meine Division aufleveln.
Und danach machen wir eine andere Division.
Ich glaube, es ist selbst nett. Ich meine, hallo? Was ist da los?
Shotgun Division. Lieber Infanterie, da kriegst du Stalker. Ist Stalker so was wie Ghost, das man einen nicht auf der Map sieht?
Wer kommt hier jetzt hoch? Oder nicht? Wo ist hier was? Wie kommt man da oben auf Schiff drauf?
Fuck, das sind Gegner. Instantot. Schalldämpfer. Bringt Schalldämpfer wirklich was?
Ich meine, es wird wie in jedem Call of Duty sein, dass man nicht auf der Map ist, aber die Range ist mal richtig für einen Kacke.
Ja, er hat sich geklaufen und immer ins Gesicht geballert. Warum hat ein Kriegsschiff Holzboten an der Decke?
Weißt du, warst du damals dabei? Weißt du, dass es nicht so war? Ah, das werden random Lootboxen verteilt? Das ist gar nicht von CS abgeguckt.
Schalldämpfer machst du mit 2 dran. Rücks muss 2 drücken.
Oh, Extended Max. Das ist schön, das brauche ich. Extended Max dafür ist gut. Extended Max ist gut, da kann man so richtig schön sprayen mit.
Was haben wir sonst noch hier? Sonst was Neues frei? Was schaltet man?
Wisst ihr, was ich blöd finde? Warum zeigen die einem nicht einfach an, was das macht? Ich meine, es ist doch schön und gut, dass es available at rank 20 ist, ja?
Aber warum zeigen die mir nicht schon vorher an, was das macht, dass man sich drauf freuen kann? Klingt irgendwie so ein bisschen nach Design Fail.
Keckstream, du musst den Leuten nicht beim Loot öffnen zugucken, du kannst den Leuten beim Loot öffnen zugucken und die Leute können dir beim Loot öffnen zugucken.
Kommt drauf an, wo du dein Loot hinschmeißt.
Max, Overwatch dead für dich? Nee, Overwatch ist überhaupt nicht dead für mich. Ich gucke immer noch sau gerne Overwatch.
Ich habe auch letztens, ich habe also BlizzCon World Cup geguckt, auch bis zum Finale nachts um 2 Uhr oder wann das gewesen ist, immer geguckt.
Aber ich kann einfach solo ranked aktuell den Overwatchen spielen, das machen meine Nerven nicht mit.
Kackgranate.
Wenn du willst, kann ich dir auch gleich noch erzählen, warum, aber ich lasse es erstmal sein, weil das erzähle ich glaube ich jeden Stream, warum er auf Overwatch ranked auf den Sack geht.
Wahrscheinlich können es die Leute schon gar nicht mehr.
Okay, Schalldämpfer dran, ihr habt ja recht, Schalldämpfer dran.
Ich kann es noch null einschätzen, von wo hier Gegner kommen, außer dass jetzt von...
Sniper.
Ey, die Sniper in dem Spiel, das fuckt mich so ab.
Ups, der war ja noch drauf, der Schalldämpfer.
What the fuck?
Was ist denn hier gerade los?
Alter, wir sind, wir spawnen hier.
Ich muss weg, ich komme nicht aus dem Spawn, ich komme nicht aus dem Spawn raus, was soll ich denn machen?
Perfekte Spawns, zurück snipen wir, das mache ich gleich.
Gleich ist Max Snipes am Start.
Warte, Bällchen.
Ich erzähle gleich, falls ich es vergesse, erzähle ich gleich, ich muss mich erstmal konzentrieren.
Ich warte Bällchen, das ist ja grausam.
Welche Hautfarbe hast du, Orange?
Ok, wo kommt hier was lang?
Ich mache mir jetzt gleich eine Sniper Klasse.
Warte Bällchen.
So, ich mache mir jetzt eine Sniper Klasse.
Also mit Schalldämpfer killst du nichts.
Ja, also auf auf was schwenkt, warum ich das nicht spielen kann, hat mehrere Gründe.
Das erste, was mir auf den Sack geht, ist, dass diese ganze Wontrick Kacke immer noch gefördert wird.
Wobei gefördert wird vielleicht das falsche Wort, ist, dass es überhaupt geht.
Was sind die Sniper? Sniper hier, Mountain, Mountain ist Sniper.
Perfekt, das nehmen wir jetzt. Jetzt wird geschneibt.
Wo bin ich denn stehen geblieben? Genau, auf was schwenkt.
Also, die ganze Wontrick Geschichte geht mir auf den Sack.
Mich nervt es einfach auch, dass überhaupt so etwas möglich ist, wie dass man Mercy Wontrick Grandmaster sein kann.
Das ist eine Sache, weil man muss ehrlich sehen, in Overwatch ist es so, dass das ganze skaliert nicht unbedingt so mit einem Held.
Also es gibt nur ganz wenige Helden, so was wie sagen wir mal jetzt Genji, Tracer, vielleicht noch irgendwie sowas über Tanks wie Zarya oder sowas.
Es gibt nur wenige Helden, die wirklich sehr viel Übung brauchen und wenn man viel Zeit drin hat, man immer noch ein bisschen besser werden kann.
Da gibt es vielleicht mal eine Hand voll.
Das heißt, das skaliert ein bisschen darüber.
Was? Warum stirbt der nicht? Ach, das ist so ein kack Auto Sniper. Ich dachte das ist ein One Shot.
Das heißt, es skaliert über die Helden, die man kann.
Und wenn man quasi einen Held wie Mercy spielen kann, bis Grandmaster komplett, ist das irgendwie Fail.
Das ist das erste. Das nächste ist, dass es halt diese zusammengewürfelte Mixed Queue gibt.
Da kommt selten Teamplay auf. Es gibt ganz viel Rumgetrolle und Rumgekacke halt. Irgendwelche Leute, die keinen Bock haben. Irgendwelche Leute, die einfach dann zu Metra spielen müssen.
Die Waffe sackt. Ich brauche so eine richtige 360 No Scope One Shot Carbine Sniper.
Kann ich da etwas anderes ausrüsten? Ich muss mir noch ein anderes Sniper holen. Das ist richtiger Mist.
So, das geht mir auch noch auf den Keks. Es gibt einige Punkte noch.
Aber mein Multitasking ist gerade nicht so. Ich kann gerade nicht spielen und mir darüber Gedanken machen.
Was gibt es sonst noch in Overwatch, was mir auf den Keks geht?
One Trick Geschichte, dass es keine Solo Queue gibt. Ich habe es mir irgendwo aufgeschrieben.
Oder guck mal bei den letzten Streams. Ich erzähle das jedes Mal. Gibt es auch viele Sachen. Ich kann das gerade so nicht spielen.
Das nervt mich.
So, jetzt haben wir eine ordentliche Sniper. Jetzt machen wir nochmal eine Infanterie Klasse.
Mit STG44. Das Ding war gut in der Beta. Kann ich mich noch daran erinnern.
Probieren wir mal ein bisschen was aus.
Loll ist nicht mein Game.
Eine der Sachen, die mich am meisten stört, ist, dass so One Trick Geschichten überhaupt gehen.
Und Blizzard sagt, sie wollen das Reporting System verbessern, damit die Trollen schneller gewandt werden.
Aber zu one tricken ist kein Troll. Das ist legitim aus der Sicht des Games.
Kann man auch verstehen. Das Problem ist bloß, wenn der Held einfach sackt, der gewone tricked wird.
Und man es trotzdem schafft, quasi in Grandmaster damit zu spielen. Irgendetwas stimmt da nicht.
Wie findest du den War Modus? Hab ich nur in der Beta gespielt. Fand ich ganz gut.
So, jetzt wird geschneibt. Ist das jetzt eine Ball-Action? Ja.
Man setzt ein bisschen hoch für.
Da hinten ist was. Es wird hart scoped.
Wo sind Gegner?
Das sah aus wie ein Gegner von mir. Jetzt haben wir schon die geile Sniper. Jetzt ist alles tot.
Ich will jetzt mal geile Sniper Kills machen.
Andere Seite.
Hallo? Wo sind die Gegner?
Kann man einfach in der Mitte stehen und schneidern.
Gegner? Da kommt in der Mitte was.
Und wo war das denn? Montage Inc.
Da unten rechts auf der anderen Seite.
Wie die ganzen Sniper rumrennen. Ich glaube das ist kein Game für mich. Da wird zu viel geschnippert.
Achtung noch Scope.
Gibt es einen Crown von Modus? Keine Ahnung.
Oh Mann. Ich check null wo Gegner sind.
Auch hinter mir. Kommt von links. Ist aber Down anscheinend.
Von hinten. Der Flow erschließt sich mir null. Wo Gegner sind und wo nicht.
Der Typ geht ab.
Wie fällt das Ding aus? Hier ist ein Toter neben mir.
Wie alt bist du? Ich bin 33.
Was? Wieder war nicht drauf.
Und wir kriegen auf den Sack. Mir fällt es auch mega schwer einzuschätzen aus welcher Richtung die Gegner kommen.
Verstecken wir uns mal in der Hoffnung dass er hier nicht herkommt. Ich check es nicht.
Ich bin der Sniper King. Das kann man ja wenigstens üben.
Ich bin schlicht zu alt. Ja das wird es sein.
Das war ein Hitmarker. Warum ist er nicht gestorben?
Warum ist er nicht gestorben? Das war ein Hitmarker.
Ich bin schlicht zu alt.
Seit dem Battlefield Video spätestens weiß man wie ich ausschaue.
Ich habe Sachen anlockt für die Sniper.
Das Attachment ist eigentlich ein kürzerer Scope als das was ursprünglich drauf ist.
Probieren wir es trotzdem mal aus.
Hab ich hier irgendwelche Fragen übersehen?
Da habe ich mich ja auch schon mal in einem Video ausgelassen was mir da auf den Keks geht.
Man hat es jetzt beim World Cup gesehen. 150.000 Zuschauer.
Ich glaube ich mache mir noch eine Airborne.
Ich brauche ein bisschen länger bis ich in ein Game reingekommen bin.
Das habe ich bei Overwatch gesehen.
Bis ich reingekommen bin. Aber dann ging das ab.
Wo sind die Gegner? Wo sind da Enemys?
Da kann es nichts machen. Drei Gegner voll.
Man kann bei jedem Game etwas rausholen indem man vorher schon eine Ahnung hat was als nächstes passiert.
Warum habe ich wieder nur 67 FPS?
Das war so schlecht gerade.
Ja das ist Absicht. Sieht besser aus.
Was?
30 FPS sind zu wenig.
Aktuell würde ich sagen nein.
Jetzt geht es ab.
Es ruckelt. Wie kann das sein?
Ich habe gerade einen Triple Collateral Sniper gerissen.
Das war schön OP Brand Munition.
Das Spiel sieht aus wie 20 FPS.